[موسيقى
] أردت أن أوضح لك كيفية صنع قناع
هنا ،
خذ باندانا مثل هذا وقم
بطيه وتأكد من طيه بشكل
صحيح لأنني أعرض هذا ، تذكر أنك
لا تريد أن تأخذ قناع العاملين بالمستشفى
لهذا السبب  أعرض لك هذا
وتذكر أنه يجب عليك ارتداء القناع
إذا ذهبت في الأماكن العامة ولكن فقط إذا كنت
تشعر أنك لا تستطيع المسافة الاجتماعية ، فلن
تحتاج إلى ارتداء هذا إذا كنت ستذهب فقط
في نزهة على سبيل المثال  بنفسك
وتذكر أيضًا أنك تفعل هذا
لمحاولة منع نفسك
من وضع الفيروس في الهواء ،
يجب على الجميع التصرف كما لو كان مصابًا
بالفيروس ، وهذا ليس ضروريًا
لحمايتك ،
بل لحماية الآخرين منك ، لذا قم
بطي المنديل هنا  نصيحة احترافية
لا تستخدم عصابات شعر صغيرة مثل هذه ،
ابحث عن عصابات شعر كبيرة ،
ضع واحدة على أي من طرفيها هنا ،
افعل هذا ، ثم ستكون هذه
خطوة رئيسية هنا
ضعها على هذا النحو ، ثم قم بطي أحد
طرفيها وثبتها حقًا  داخل الآخر ادخل هناك
مثل هذا لن يكون هذا
موضة  بيان
ولكن هناك تذهب وهناك
مناندانا تقوم بالمهمة تمنعني من نشر
الفيروس الذي تخلعه ، يمكنك
الوصول إلى هنا مرة أخرى مثل هذا التظاهر
بأن البندانة ملوثة
يمكنك وضعها في الغسيل إذا كان
لديك قناع مثل هذا هذا واحد  أن
ابنتي
جعلتني يجب أن تتعلم كيف تربط
خلف رأسك كما يفعل الجراحون أو تجعل
شخصًا ما يفعل ذلك نيابةً عنك ولكن
يفضل أن تفعل كل شيء بنفسك
ثم مرة أخرى عندما تخلعه
لا تلمس  أمام القناع
خلعه ضعه في
الغسيل الكثير من الأسئلة حول
التمساح ، هناك الكثير من الناس لديهم هذه الأشياء
التي يمكن أن تكون فعالة ولكن إليك
المشكلة يقوم الكثير من الأشخاص بتعديلها باستمرار ،
لذا كن حذرًا إذا كنت تستخدم واحدًا من  هذه
الأهم من ذلك كله ،
البقاء في المنزل قدر الإمكان ، والخروج
فقط إذا كنت مضطرًا لارتداء قناع
إذا كنت ستعيش في مكان
لا يمكنك أن
تبقى فيه بأمان في
ظل فيروس كورونا ، فهناك إبداع
يرتدي قناعًا  هونغ كون  يُظهر لي الفنان g tikka
من الشرق الفن الذي ابتكره
على جهاز iPad الخاص
به ، حيث يُظهر عاملاً من هونج كونج يرتدي
قناعًا جراحيًا يقاتل فيروسًا شيطانيًا
مثل بطل خارق
من البداية هونج كونج
وقد أوصت العديد من الحكومات الآسيوية الأخرى
بارتداء الأقنعة في الأماكن العامة
سواء  كانت تظهر عليهم الأعراض أو لا تظهر عليهم الأعراض
في وقت مبكر من مارس / آذار ، وكان هونغ كونغ 150
حالة إصابة فقط بالفيروس
على الرغم من كونها واحدة من الأماكن الأولى التي أبلغت فيها
عن الإصابات المؤكدة
خارج الصين القارية ، إلا أن المدينة
شهدت ارتفاعًا حادًا فقط بعد عودة الأشخاص من
أوروبا والولايات المتحدة
هنا في هونغ.  كان يرتدي kong
القناع حقيقة من حقائق الحياة منذ
يناير الآن بأيدٍ نظيفة ، أرتدي
قناعي مثل هذا
مع التأكد من أن هذا تحت ذقني
وأن السلك مثني فوق جسر
أنفي وأرتدي هذا في
كل مرة أذهب  في مكان مزدحم
مثل المنتزه أو السوبر
ماركت ، لا يقتصر الأمر على تقليل
حالات الإصابة بالفيروسات المزمنة التي تعرفها فحسب ،
بل إنه يؤدي أيضًا إلى خفض الإنفلونزا في الواقع ،
هذا هو الآن موسم الأنفلونزا ، وبالكاد نرى
أي حالات مؤثرة وذلك لأن
المريخ لا تحمي فعليًا من
الفيروسات المزمنة فحسب ، بل تحمي أيضًا من
فيروسات الأنفلونزا وكذلك
للسيطرة على الوباء ، قامت هونج كونج
بعزل حالات عزل
مخالطيهم وشجعت على التباعد الاجتماعي
ولكن بينما تواصل هونج كونج
تشجيع الاستخدام الجماعي
لم يقم المسؤولون الأمريكيون إلى حد كبير بالتغريد في أواخر
فبراير / شباط ، عندما توقف الجراح الأمريكي العام
عن شراء الأقنعة ،
فهي ليست فعالة في منع
عامة الناس من الإصابة بفيروس كرونوفيروس ،
ولكن إذا لم يتمكن مقدمو الرعاية الصحية من
حملهم على رعاية المرضى المرضى ،
فإن ذلك يضعهم ويضعهم لدينا.  المجتمعات المعرضة للخطر
ولكن هناك أدلة متزايدة على أن
الأقنعة فعالة
وفقًا لدراسة للتدخلات
المستخدمة خلال تفشي مرض سارس عام 2003
، ارتبط ارتداء القناع باستمرار في الأماكن العامة
بتخفيض خطر الإصابة بمرض السارس بمقدار 70 عامًا ، وفقًا
لدراسة حديثة أجريت في مستشفى لانسيت.
النصيحة المتناقضة من الحكومات
بشأن ارتداء
الأقنعة أيدها المؤلفون  في ظل ظروف معينة ،
فإن الأولوية القصوى هي التأكد من حصولنا على
كتلة كافية للعاملين في مجال الرعاية الصحية
لأنهم يحتاجون إليها حقًا
وعلينا التأكد من وجود ما يكفي لهم ، فنحن
نعلم أن ارتداء
القناع أفضل من عدم ارتداء قناع ولكن
في نفس الوقت  الوقت بالطبع هو
البقاء في المنزل هو أفضل طريقة لتجنب
الإصابة
بالعدوى يقول الكرنك إن القناع يمكن أن يساعد في حماية
مرتديه الأصحاء من استنشاق
الجزيئات المعدية
أو لمس وجوههم بأيدي ملوثة
ولكن الحماية الأكبر تأتي
من تغطية أفواه الناقلين الصامتين
للأشخاص المصابين بالفعل ولكن  لا أعرف
ذلك حتى الآن
وهذا تبرير جيد جدًا
لاستخدام الطحلب خاصة بالنسبة لـ
covid19 حيث نعلم أنه في
بعض الحالات
يمكن للأشخاص نشر العدوى قبل
ظهور أعراضهم من
خلال حملات المعلومات العامة التي
يتم تعليم الناس في هونغ كونغ كيفية
ارتداء القناع بشكل صحيح
ويفعله الجميع تقريبًا ، يعد هذا
رمزًا قويًا للتضامن حيث يقوم الأفراد
بحماية بعضهم البعض للمساعدة
أنهي هذا
الوباء ، نحن حوالي أربعة وربع
بالمائة من سكان العالم
أه ما لدينا ومع ذلك لدينا
نسب عالية بشكل غير متناسب عندما يتعلق الأمر بحالات
الفيروس ووفيات الفيروس التاجي ،
فلماذا أعني أن الناس
متشككون في بعض  الأرقام التي
نسمعها من
الصين أو إيران أو روسيا وربما
هناك الكثير مما يحدث هناك
لا نعرف عنه ولكن
لا يزال لدينا فيروس كورونا هنا أكثر
من البلدان الأخرى
جيدًا أعتقد أننا تصرفنا
متأخرًا
يعني أنك تعلم وهذا أه
سيكون هناك متسع من الوقت
للقيام نوعًا ما بأثر رجعي حول هذا ولكن
أعتقد أننا لم نختبر بشكل
كاف ونتيجة لذلك في المجتمعات في جميع
أنحاء البلاد عندما كنا
نسمع أنك تعلم ربما كان هناك
50  أو 60 حالة في البلاد خلال تلك
الفترة الزمنية
كان الفيروس ينتشر بقوة في
هذه المجتمعات وكان كثير من الناس
يصابون
بالمشكلة هل يستغرق الأمر ثلاثة أسابيع
بين وقت التعرض و  الوقت الذي
قد يموت فيه شخص ما بسبب هذا حتى تعرف أننا
ما زلنا نرى
تداعيات ذلك الجاك لمجرد أنك تعلم أن
نصيب الفرد مهم حقًا هنا
لأننا نجري الكثير من الاختبارات هنا
ولكنها ليست موزعة بشكل موحد
و  لقد حدث الجزء الأكبر من هذا الاختبار
مؤخرًا ،
أنت تعلم أننا نتحدث عن
إجمالي عدد الاختبارات أيًا كان ما يقرب من 2
مليون وأعتقد أنه يتغير الآن كل يوم ،
لكن هذا كان الجزء الأكبر من ذلك حدث للتو
خلال الأسبوعين الماضيين ، كنت ترغب
في حدوث ذلك  مبكرًا
وبشكل موحد ولم يكن لدينا ذلك